hello and welcome to this video playing
drain you that sooner Burke Hanson he is
currently in Baku why don't you see
Azerbaijani flat so it's a little bit
surprising that he and they also play in
like one an hour what not what sad so
what is he doing anyway let's see what
happens kind of kind of funny okay so
getting those of stuff this is a good
line for white um so there is that
sometimes d5 here in this put in these
positions look here okay I'm gonna go
for that it's quite often decent IDM
yeah yes fatigued with the night there's
not much else so and all right I
actually did not consider politics at
all but it is of course very serious
option that's sad that is sad okay it's
not all that clear how bad this this is
but I should have seen what the X at
least recognize it as a possible option
okay I think you will just cancel
probably on
can't Quintus and this is also
interesting yeah I think I can hardly do
without counseling and the good thing
about this move is he prevents Quincy
five or makes it far less attractive
however this is hanging only to maybe
there is something based on that Aquino
g4s is a move on take screen shakes it
looks very shaky on the dark squares not
very convincing Quincy fire I don't
quite know here i will just rip the
eighth for some c6 yeah that clearly
went wrong
that went wrong added my line with
bishop before check I need to refresh
that or replace that with my current
knowledge I I tend to get into trouble
against good against good players and I
mean the the Scotch is a is a good
opening but I should should be in that
trouble okay knight c6 here is that
doing anything not really it's ready for
Knight c3 in this position how can I set
him some problems yeah I don't see it
really see 693 it's just solid me just
solid don't really see something great I
mean great I would have been okay with
something that looks playable I didn't
see anything that looks playable yeah
okay here at least I have the check and
night before it it said something or
b-five maybe in Toronto and this is
actually at least looking somewhat
interesting if it takes it Quincy five
checkup takes d5 that would work
okay now Bishop takes as a check maybe
maybe this isn't all all that clear 94
is an issue here of course let's go here
first yep that's the issue that's the
issue oh it's 94 Bishop c4 yeah it's not
good it's not good still not good
I think my position maybe was even worse
at some point but it's still bad it's
still pretty bad so what to do crew two
before would be good if I can get that
in making a bit of pressure on be too I
mean it's not much but time morning
getting be two would be good because it
also makes the night unstable but I
don't expect that to happen I think you
will probably cover it somehow yeah rook
e8 now statim said something the
background is somewhat weak I can't take
no I cannot shoot okay
surprising you didn't take that and I
probably just looking for a property to
or something maybe
still not towards totally easy I have to
break this break this break the serve up
something and somehow otherwise I'm just
getting crushed probably if can crush it
as well but it still feels like the only
option and he's getting down on time a
little bit that was the best option
check check check check check check I'm
a queen shoot pre widest oh my god ah
yeah okay yeah well I level certainly
losing at some point trade this very
well out all of the opening yeah i don't
know i really have to refresh stuff here
I mean this is just not an acceptable
opening result black it's just in
terrible shape him he has this somehow
felt a little bit I like things were
getting a bit better but it's still not
it's still not good here yes I'm not
losing immediately but it's still a bad
position yeah now you're just better all
the way I'm just hanging on that same
and he probably just makes a mistake
somewhat later look D to e 2 things
winning here according to the engine and
this is also not bad yeah this is this
seems to spoil it night a for this win
problems probably because here there is
no it's five
yet here I am ok I was also playing for
Winnie I think here the chest I have the
bishop my king is potentially active I
wasn't playing on Tommy if you think
about that yeah Chad this is scramble
chapter you can click click click on
just a pre move fest anyway yeah tough
game i'd have to have to do something
about this opening it's a little bit
it's a little bit too bad ok well thanks
for watching